an extraordinary morning here in Beijing
we're at the number one intermediate
court in the west of the city and we've
witnessed over the past two hours
the treatment of people who are willing
and brave enough if you like to speak
out against the Chinese government just
about 20 minutes ago just over there a
group of 20 or so actors who was
supporting the people who are in the
court right now and the courthouse is
behind me over the other side of the
road they put up banners those banners
were quickly torn down they were then
asked to get in police found or taken
into police vans and from there they
were taken away and you could see a
gentleman here from the police is
actually trying to stop us from doing
what we're doing now this is some hope
you can still see us we'll move back a
bit so I could try and explain the
background to the story shoot you young
if you could still hear me well I
suppose I just do a sense of what it's
about you've got here a plane closed
official this has been going on all
morning we have been able to get up live
until now these people work for the
Chinese government they've been
preventing us from filming we haven't
got any access to the course itself we
tried to put up our live position the
other side of the road and my colleague
Andy porch was wrestled to the ground at
one point his blue card as we call it
their press cards that we all have to
carry has been taken away from him they
tried to take away our tapes didn't
manage to in this case I suppose what's
happening to journalist is a side issue
given what's happening to the activists
themselves it's all about Xu Zhu young
Hanna he is a very well-known academic
from a Beijing University he was
arrested in July last year once again
you could see the plane closed officials
trying to move us on shoot you young was
arrested in July last year for trying to
speak out against the government oddly
he was trying I'm just trying to explain
the story is that okay choo choo young
was trying to expose corruption in China
and as he did he was arrested he's on
trial in this courthouse now and this
Hanna is the sort of thing we have to
deal with on a daily basis when we try
to report what the Chinese government
doesn't appear to want us to report I
think we'll probably hand it back to
Yuna
why can't I report this I'm allowed to
be here
we are allowed to report here why are we
not allowed to report this why am I not
allowed to stand here yeah it's very
strange you know trying to report a
court case in China this is what happens
I will try and explain the background to
it because it is important as I said
shoot you young the leader of a movement
in China which was trying to expose
corruption the irony of course is that
the Chinese President himself has said
he wants to expose corruption he wants
to arrest people who are corrupt and at
the top levels of government that's what
they've been doing but when anyone lower
down in society tries to expose what
they perceive as corruption they're
arrested that's what's happened to shoot
you young